hey everybody you know that I'm not the
biggest gym rat in the world I just woke
up like this you know I just this is
just all natural I
don't not go to the gym because I think
it's bad to go to the gym exactly it'd
probably be good if I were just a big
Beefcake I don't go to the gym because
you know I'm just like kind of lazy in
the morning and I don't want to go now I
have another reason not to go to the gym
because my friends who do work out tell
me that an evil creature has infested
gymnasia around the country and that
would be Tick Tock girls they go and
they harass men and make guys who just
want to go pump a little iron get some
blood flowing they make them feel like
weirdos and creeps and it's got to stop
so we will examine this phenomenon take
it away with the first Tick Tock this is
how to not approach girls at the gym
I hate this night because I hate when
they're sweet ass stay so uncomfortable
feral like feral all right
excuse me
you don't have to do that it's okay no
no it's okay I got it thank you though
foreign
why do men and women go to the same gym
this seems like a recipe for disaster
from what I can tell the thing that this
woman is complaining about is that she
went to a place where men are getting
blood pumping testosterone bursting
through their bodies and then these
women show up wearing dental floss and
they kind of prance and jiggle around a
little bit and then believe it or not
the men sometimes look at them and this
is very bad they definitely don't want
that that's why they're wearing very
tight skimpy outfits and going to the
men's gym for some reason and filming
themselves because they hate they
obviously hate that male attention right
this could easily be solved though
by just having different gyms for men
and women I don't want to have women
looking at me while I'm pumping iron
that's not what I'm there for by the way
she's saying this guy's really creepy
because he comes over to her to help her
out men help each other out in the gym
even if this were an all-male gym the
guy would come over hey you need some
help with the way it's hey you need a
spotter you need that's like a normal
thing
that women
trying to destroy these the specific
subset of tick-tock women next one
[Music]
I'm so uncomfortable right now I'm so
uncomfortable that I'm going to set up a
film shoot
specifically to catch men looking at me
I'm gonna I'm going to display myself
for men and then for the whole world
that's how uncomfortable I am obviously
she's not uncomfortable obviously she's
very comfortable and she's exploiting
these poor guys and it's like you know
dangling a nice juicy cupcake in front
of a flooding you know and saying hey
hey why are you looking at the cupcake
that's a crazy thing of course
when I say that men and women shouldn't
use the same gems
people are probably going to call me the
Taliban or something they're going to
say I want to impose Sharia law or
something like that I'm just hearing
what the women are saying is the woman's
solution that men should stop being
attracted to women well the libs have
done a decent job of spreading that
through Society but it's not ever going
to actually work if this is really
bothering certain women there's a very
simple answer maybe men and women should
have at least certain spaces that are a
little bit separate particularly spaces
where they're not wearing a lot of
clothing and they're sweating and
they've got all sorts of hormones and
and blood and everything's bumping
through them and they're being very
virile and energized maybe that would be
a good idea maybe it turns out
older times with more modest cultures
maybe they weren't just totally crazy
maybe they understood a little something
about human nature that we have
forgotten right now go to genucel.com
knowlesyt as you might know we are all
big fans of our friends over at
geniusell don't just take my word for it
Ella from Rockford says quote I have
both age and acne spots and this stuff
is actually fading both of them this
Serum is worth every penny Ella is
raving about the famous Dark Spot
Corrector from gen yusel a must-have
after months of record heat and humidity
sunspots brown spots discoloration and
even red inflamed patches all disappear
in front of your very eyes and here's
the geniusell amazing guarantee you will
see results on day one or your money
back so take advantage of geniusell's
most popular package which now includes
the Dark Spot Corrector plus the classic
geniusell bags and puffiness treatment
and immediate effects all at about
seventy seven zero percent off so you
can try the best skincare in the world
for yourself completely risk free it's
simple go to
geniusell.comyt and start looking years
even decades younger tomorrow say
goodbye to dark and liver spots bags and
puffiness under the eyes crow's feet at
genucel.com knowlesyt geniusell.com
Knowles letter y letter T encountered a
gym creeper today obviously this guy's
not dressed for a good workout put a
pause there that is a great workout
outfit why is that not workout gear
that's it's very casual the shirt
doesn't have a collar it doesn't have
any buttons he's wearing blue jeans it's
not like he's wearing wool trousers that
looks perfectly appropriate to me
why is she staring at him she's so upset
that he's staring why is she staring at
him and ogling him and objectifying him
next video watch this I get angry when I
do a handstand
[Music]
because you're somewhat attractive at
least and aren't wearing a lot of
clothing I guess that's the answer to
all of these
and it's something that women have been
doing since the dawn of time and it's
kind of charming when they're young
women doing it when you know when you're
in high school you say tea why are you
boys looking at me but it's much less
Charming as you grow up and become an
adult and should know the answer to that
question
why are men paying attention to you
because you were you were doing the
sorts of things that demand the
attention of men that's why am I like
hot or something
yes will it will you feel better if I
say yes sure that's why oh what you
think I'm like pretty yeah I guess so
that's so weird yeah okay okay lady can
we get our culture in any way mature
past the age of 16 I'm no longer
convinced we need a good swimming gym we
need a goose
oh we need the existing gyms to give us
like
days of the week that we could go to
when no guys are going to be in the gym
can we get this please great idea yeah
that's great sure okay she's I I
wouldn't classify her as one of the gym
girls she's like the opposite of these
gym girls
because these gym girls are going there
intentionally to just humiliate men the
reason a man goes to the gym is to be
excellent to engage in physical
Excellence so that he can look better
and be healthier and feel better and
what these women are doing is showing up
and trying to undercut and humiliate
them at every single step of the way
yeah and to tantalize them and tease
them and and distract them from what
they're actually there to do if a guy
wants to pick up a girl he's going to go
to a bar he's going to go to a club he's
going to go to I don't know some guy if
he's more wholesome he'll go to the
church picnic but he's going to go to a
place where that sort of thing is
intended to happen that's not his
primary motivation for going to the gym
so then that lady comes around she goes
hey if this is a problem we should just
have separate Gym hours or separate gyms
right yeah totally but none of these
Tick Tock girls are going to want that
if the men and the women went to
different gyms or the same gym at
different times they would lose all
their likes and their views watch this
guy try move to me at the gym
okay this is not Jack's ABS this is not
fit for nothing on his phone me being
busy sorting my wrist straps look I'm
legitimately gonna stop this is not
conducive to Virtue to look at this
video I'm gonna look into the camera
instead
sad list
why why did she place the camera there
why that angle why those shorts why
it it's true
that
men need to
avert their eyes sometimes if
something's a little bit attractive
Frank what nonetheless like things
anymore women can help though you know
you can yes the man has the
responsibility to be in control of his
lusts and things like that the women
have a responsibility not to wear that
and film that from that camera angle
lady also because it undercuts the
argument that they don't want male
attention they crave it and we shouldn't
give it to them we should listen to that
Trinidadian lady
and get separate Gym hours and then all
my friends who go to the gym can tell me
about how it works out see you next time
a day may come from the courage of men
fails but it is not this day